Amal Clooney looks a fashionable as ever  while heading to work in NYC while  mary-kate and Ashley Olsen settle a  legal battle  [Music]  according to court documents obtained by  ET Mary Kate Nash Lee's company dual  star Entertainment Group will be paying  up to a hundred and forty thousand  dollars to a group of former interns who  alleged in a 2015 class-action lawsuit  they were either unpaid or paid less  than minimum wage  after working extended hours you gotta  kid another fashionista who is  well-versed in legal woes Amal Clooney I  think she likes working the pregnant  human rights lawyer stunned while out in  New York City Thursday giving us major  Jackie O vibes in this vintage-inspired  yellow and black cap sleeve dress and  matching coat George Clooney's wife  accessorized her ensemble with black  pumps a matching handbag and Sonny's and  her adorable growing belly while heading  into the UN to talk international  affairs  you